Hershey's showed this just just
yesterday
Hershey showed this with the
her for she campaign
her for she campaign was for
international women's day and what
Hershey did was they went all feminist
but there was a Twist on it they went
feminist
and then cast a man dressed as a woman
in the role of the woman for
international women's day
my name is Faye Johnstone I'm the
executive director of wisdom to action
we can create a world where everyone is
able to live in public space as their
honest and authentic selves see the
woman changing how we see the future at
Hershey's Canada
I know
I know everyone knows
it's so offensive in every way to every
group it seems
it's so offensive that you know
it crossed Jeremy's mind right you know
so actually some of you tweeted it at us
he said this company this won't eat my
chocolate but this company is just
rubbing my face in this stupid not only
woke feminist ideology but this woke
trans feminist
you know it crossed Jeremy's mind
but you probably thought
there's no way
there's no way but Jeremy
would actually launch
a Chocolate Company If he if he did
there's no way that he would do it
on the very day that Hershey's launched
the trans campaign right
well just because we launched Jeremy's
razors after Harry's canceled
conservatives took on Disney with hiring
Gina Carano after they canceled or sued
the federal government over the vax
Mandate and won
people think
that we can just take on every woke
company when they make these ridiculous
statements of course we can't do that
every time
or can we
[Music]
you might be thinking how could you have
launched a chocolate company in one day
well they don't call him the god king
for nothing don't wait pre-order your
Jeremy's chocolate now
at ihatehersheys.com
that is ihatehersheys.com
get your he him and she her chocolate
bars today yet another way to stop
giving your money to woke corporations
that hate you
back to Hershey's for a second
Hershey's Hershey's
made an error here I think and irritated
a lot of the customers but they they
exposed something that a lot of people
don't understand about the way our
culture works a lot of people believe
that the problem that our society faces
is that we put too much value on our
bodies on material Goods on the stuff of
this world we deny the soul we deny
metaphysical morality we deny we deny
everything right
no
what what this Hershey's ad and
transgenderism broadly what what it
shows you is that increasingly we think
the body doesn't matter at all
increasingly
we live our lives digitally increasingly
we live our lives on our phones or in
the metaverse or online Internet forums
and so we don't think the Body Matters
we think it can all be we Zoom we Skype
It's All Digital we work from home
no this is where the meme of go touch
grass comes from people saying go put
down the screens go outside go do
something go do something in the real
world with real people in real time in
space
because if we live our lives as though
the body doesn't matter we're going to
come to think that the body doesn't
matter Lexa Randy likes credenti
if we if we live our lives just like
couch potatoes plugged into the Matrix
where we do everything digitally
then then
we're not only are we going to accept
trans ideology we're going to accept all
of it even if we don't want to because
belief follows
our Behavior and the rituals that we
engage in no surprise here from
Hershey's but it's something that we
should all watch out for the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member and use code
Knowles can a wlas a checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you